we know that after 15 years people who
commit sex offences desist
that's ridiculous okay wait wait kid
please they don't age Mehta
a meta-analysis of 21 studies by Carl
Hanson showed across the board there is
distance even for the highest was the
lowest risk right away have a 1 to 5
percent chance of repeating I'm not
assuming it's a meta-analysis I didn't
do it it's my Carl Hanson it was
published in 2014
welcome to the Scylla forum we're a
monthly debate series that features
topics of special interest to
libertarians and aims to enhance social
and professional ties within New York
City's libertarian community this is an
Oxford style debate in which the
audience
initially votes for against or undecided
on the resolution and then again after
the debate is over whoever moves the
debate in his or her favor is declared
the winner go into Soho vote.com Soho
vote.com
to Kent to cast your initial vote you'll
find the tonight's resolution reads all
the laws requiring those convicted of
sex offenses to put their names in a
registry should be abolished we're
partners with Reason magazine and
presenting these debates and you can
catch audio of all our events on the
reason podcast which you'll find on the
iTunes Store thanks also to the Smith
Family Foundation for making this series
possible for more information and to buy
tickets to our future debates go to our
website at the soho forum dot org I'm
Jean Epstein director of the so forum
arguing for the affirmative on the
resolution we have sociologist Emily
Horowitz author of protecting our kids
how sex offender laws are failing us
Emily please come to the stage
opposing the resolution we have Marcy
Hamilton author of justice denied what
America must do to protect its children
Marcy please come to the stage
Jane please close the initial vote
Emily harlots please take the podium and
give us your defense of the resolution
take it away Emily okay Thank You Jean
thank you Jane thank you everyone at the
Soho forum thank you reason for
sponsoring this debate and taking on
this challenging and emotional topic
first some caveats this is a very
complicated issue one that puts our
emotions at war with our heads and with
the facts second this is really to me
about the world we want for ourselves
and our children how do we reckon with
wrongdoing as well as the injury and
trauma that people suffer from sex
offenses do we want accountability and
reasonable punishment or do we want to
go further and have laws that stigmatize
and label people forever tonight I'd
like to do a few things first I'm gonna
give the basics of sex offense
registries what led to registration laws
in every state and what the supporters
of these laws were saying and then I'll
explain how these laws have failed and
why more and more people are questioning
whether whether registries are needed
I'll be going against the grain after
several decades there's a huge public
support for registries however as a
sociologist and a criminologist years of
work have convinced me that registries
are very problematic I hope that we all
agree I think Marcy and I definitely
agree on this that public safety is a
priority
there must be effective efforts to lower
and prevent sex offenses and ensure
accountability when they do happen
there's a very important controversy
about the facts that I want to make sure
you know about many people believe I'm
sure many people in the
room believed that individuals who
commit sex offenses will not stop
they can't stop they will go on to Rhea
fend for top that falsehood declaring in
several landmark cases that the
recidivism rate in sex offenses is quote
frightening and high this line that the
recidivism rate for sex offenses is
quote frightening and high one into
hundreds of other Court decisions and
infected an entire area of law and
policy
after many futile Corrections efforts
the daym finally burst in 2015 an
investigatory piece in a peer-reviewed
Law Journal revealed the words came from
a therapist who was quoted in a news
magazine with no research or evidence to
back up the claim federal and state
courts use this falsehood to
rubber-stamp all kinds of terrible laws
based on this wildly exaggerated fear of
rhea fence the truth is the rhea fence
rate is about the lowest of any category
of offender fortunately this controversy
has gotten media coverage Radley Balko
in the Washington Post covered this his
piece was headlined the big lie about
sex offenders a New York Times piece was
titled when junk science about sex
offenders infects the Supreme Court
undoing the damage is a huge job but has
already begun keep in mind that
registration laws are based on fear not
on evidence until I met somebody who was
on the registry I like most of you had
never given registry as a second thought
since 1996 we've had registration laws
in all 50 states
these laws vary but each state has a
list of offenses that require
registration those list of registered
offenses are getting longer that's how
people end up on the registry what you
have to do when you're on the registry
you have to visit an office regularly
you have to have your photo taken you
have to give an update a lot of personal
information your home address age height
weight offense school and even your work
work address simply missing a deadline
for registration can result in a felony
charge in prison this personal info goes
on to the registry website which we've
all seen it's available to anyone 24/7
it's searchable by name address zip code
anything you want some states go further
with community notification
they mail postcards to neighbors they
post fliers they issue press releases
they install yard signs some states your
driver's license is stamped with sex
offender in bold letters the information
on these websites gets picked up and
redistributed by private companies media
outlets such as the local patch websites
regularly publish maps with dots to
signify where registrants live for
anyone on the registry there are other
laws to worry about local and state laws
in many states restrict where one can
live work and visit registrants are
often required to go to undergo
scientifically unreliable polygraph
testing and electronic monitoring nine
states have castration laws for sex
offenses we have extra punishment for
sex offenses these are a special set of
laws that apply to people after they've
already paid their price after they've
experienced the harsh realities of jail
prison prison probation and parole
California's registry was the first
registry it started in 1947 it tracked
gays and communists decades later in the
1990s several terrible crimes against
children had lawmakers around the
country scrambling to enact registry
statutes the laws bear their names jacob
wetterling adam walsh megan kanka
Drew's shouting these crimes were rare
but the fear and anger raged stranger
danger stranger danger became a thing
and dramatically changed the way we
raise our children the specter of these
awful cases remains so powerful that
there's support for just about any law
that will protect the children nearly
900,000 people are in registries and the
number keeps rising over 40,000 in New
York mostly men some women every age
from minors to seniors a wide range of
offenses consensual teen sex sexting
paying for sex possession of Urata
images of anyone under 18 even with no
evidence of any contact defenses public
urination and forcible offenses there's
evidence that african-american men are
landing on the registry far more often
than white men I recently edited a book
about the rash of intellectually and
developmentally disabled people who wind
up on the registry several million
people are directly impacted when family
members are included the argument for
regice
three laws is summed up in the one
phrase protect the children proponents
argued that listing offenders and their
whereabouts would keep the public safe
err when Clinton signed Megan's Law in
1996 he said there is no greater right
than a parent's right to raise a child
and safety and love today America
circles the wagons around our children
but has it worked after 20 years of
registry what do we know first the
research little research back then but a
lot has accumulated public safety
there's no rigorous evidence that the
Reg the registry improves public safety
recidivism
there's no rigorous evidence that the
registry reduces recidivism cost figures
are hard to come by but the registry
costs federal and state tax dollars very
likely several hundred million dollars
annually human impacts for those human
impacts the two words sex offender carry
more punch than just about any phrase
for those who must sign the registry the
impacts are wide and severe described as
social death by many commentators here
are some field reports to registrants
were murdered the man convicted of their
killing had found them on a registry
website and after his sentencing he said
they deserved to die he said he would
have killed more if he hadn't been
caught in Texas a talented computer
scientist with a sex offense history
came out of prison completed his PhD and
got an offer from a Silicon Valley firm
after the usual checks the offer was
withdrawn and he works in a coffee shop
the only job he can find in Grand Rapids
Michigan are registering foes to death
on the street in the winter by law -
homeless shelters were unable to give
him more warmth because both facilities
were too close to schools a graduate
student hoping to find a date online
instead got talked into a sting and
spent time in prison after two years of
fruitless job hunting he made a decision
he left the country permanently if our
concern is children stranger dangers
wildly exaggerated ninety percent of
sexual offenses against children and
teens are committed by someone they know
often a family member and almost all the
time that person is not on the registry
but a first-time offender child sexual
abuse is complex it doesn't fit the
stereotype of a much older perpetrator
about 1/3 to 1/4 of those who sexually
abuse children are other children
teens among adult perpetrators young
adults under the age of 30 are
over-represented but what matters most
for all the energy put into registries
and punishments sex crimes against
children have been declining for decades
starting before the implementation of
the registry courts for years courts
have upheld registry laws the judicial
ground is starting to shift in several
recent decisions give a glimmer a tough
federal appeals court judge wrote in an
opinion that the Michigan registry quote
creates social lepers reflecting on the
dangers of registries another federal
judge said Colorado's Registration Act
poses a quote serious threat of
retaliation violence ostracism shaming
and other unfair and irrational
treatment from the public Massachusetts
top court overturned restrictions on
where registrants can live in reference
ww2 internments she said
the days are long since passed when
communities of persons such as Native
Americans and Japanese Americans may be
lawfully banished from our mists so the
registry doesn't improve public safety
or decrease recidivism and it costs a
lot of money and has negative impacts on
the lives of registrants and their
families what would happen without it
every state has a raft of criminal
statutes as does the federal government
any concern over r-e offense is
addressed with additional penny
penalties patty Wetterling son Jacob was
abducted molested and killed she
campaigned energetically for registries
the Jacob Wetterling Act memorializes
her son since then her thinking has
changed here's what patty says now I
based my support on my assumption that
sex offenders have the highest
recidivism rate of any criminal but the
high recidivism rates I assumed to be
true do not exist it has made me rethink
the value of broad-based community
notification laws which operate on the
assumption that most sex offenders are
high-risk dangers to the community they
are released to what we really want is
no more victims don't do it again
so how can we get there locking them up
for ever labeling them and not allowing
them community support doesn't work I've
turned 180 degrees from where I was if
the mother of a murdered child can
reject registries so can we the registry
is broken it's time to replace it with
measures that actually protect our
communities thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Marci Hamilton speaking for
the negative on the resolution take it
away Marci
thanks to Jean and the Soho forum it is
comforting to know that in this divisive
era that it's possible for people to
have a civil debate even about very
heated issues which of course child sex
abuse is one of them I actually feel
sorry for my opponent in this debate in
some ways it's very hard to argue
against recidivism when Larry Nasser
just went to prison after 156 women
testified against him in court
265 have charged him with civil
litigation that's hundreds but he's not
by himself in my experience through
child USA and my work on statutes of
limitations when one victim comes
forward frequently typically many come
after now I'm actually going to agree on
one point I think that the perpetrators
that are under 18 deserve treatment not
labeling they're the ones that the
science shows can actually turn the
corner they're the ones whose lives can
be most ruined
I will also agree that we should have a
Romeo and Juliet exception if someone is
two or three years apart from the person
with whom they've had sex it's highly
unlikely that it is a sex offense but
for everybody else sex offender
registries are just one of the tools we
need to stop the pandemic of child sex
abuse the vast majority of abuse is by
individuals that are known to the victim
they are in the family their coaches
their Boy Scout leaders their priests
their rabbis the stranger-danger that we
just heard about is just largely a myth
it's the people in these children's
lives who prey on the children and how
do we know who is going to prey on a
child from one of the most informative
speeches I've ever heard from FBI expert
on child sex abuse Ken Lanning at
Cardozo law school at a symposium that I
organized immediately after the Boston
Globe stories came out about abuse there
he said the following he said you know
who's normally sexually abuses children
the nice guy the one that's got
everybody's trust the one that has the
capacity to get access and who are they
they are the people who choose jobs to
have access to many children they are
priests they are rabbis they are
teachers they are coaches they are the
people we love and then he added and by
the way they really are nice like
they're really nice people it just so
happens that they victimized children
children cannot defend themselves
against these individuals it is very
rare for there to be a false claim about
child sex abuse this has been confirmed
by study after study by the emerging
studies that are being done by child
traumatologist like the top people in
the country at Yale at the University of
Pennsylvania where I work with dr.
Stephen Berkowitz what we're dealing
with here trying to get rid of these
registries is what is at the base of
what's at fault in our culture it's the
reason our children are at risk adults
prefer and they protect adults adult
interests are always so much more
important than children children don't
vote they don't have lobbies they don't
matter but in fact they deserve our
protection and the registries for those
over 18 are just one of the ways that we
are trying to get control of a
that is harming too many children one in
four girls and one in six boys will be
sexually abused by the time they're 18
that is a stat statistic that is
confirmed again and again and again by
studies and by looking at the relevant
literature what we're talking about
tonight who's on a registry after all
you have to have either pled guilty or
you have to have been convicted and if
you're convicted you must have been
convicted beyond a reasonable doubt
we're not talking about people who are
walking down the street and someone says
you know what I saw what you did with
that child so you know what I'm gonna
put you on a registry in fact Ohio tried
that kind of a registry it's just a
random Civil Registry and in the state
of Ohio it turned out that you can't put
someone on a sex abuse registry unless
they're convicted through the criminal
court system with all of its limitations
on the ability to convict someone these
are people who are criminals one of the
arguments that is sometimes made in this
arena is that how in the world could you
put someone who just just looks at child
porn on a registry that's not fair they
haven't hurt anybody but if you look at
the science what the science tells us
now is that child porn normalizes sexual
abuse the activity of abuse it's not a
side activity it makes it easier for
someone to be likely to seek out
children today we have no effective
permanent treatment for sex offenders
for those under 18 with the right
treatment there is hope but for over 18
that treatment does not exist and so
what we are being persuaded of tonight
is that we are supposed to feel sorry
for people who have sexually assaulted
children and now other people know that
they sexually assaulted children and
we're supposed to forget it
forgive them that's not the job of the
law the job of the law is to protect the
vulnerable and the vulnerable will not
be protected if in fact we don't do
everything in our power to protect
children so how do we risk reduce the
risk of child sex abuse it's going to
take this entire culture if you watched
the Nasir story who let those children
down it was a major research university
Michigan State it was a respected doctor
dr. Larry Nasser it was the karoli ranch
down in Texas it was the US Olympic
Committee
it was USA Gymnastics the national
governing board for gymnastics and it
was every other adult every nurse every
therapist that didn't do the mandated
reporting they should have done that in
a nutshell is the problem with our
culture right now we are perfectly
capable of assuming that the man in
power deserves our protection god forbid
we would take away his livelihood
even though child after child after
child reports him there are many many
lessons to be learned from the Nasser
case but one of them is not that this is
unusual this is how it happens
second mile at Penn State did not pay
attention to the fact that they were
supplying victims to Jerry Sandusky
repeatedly the Catholic Church has
ignored to this day telling us the full
list of all the people they know that
have sexually abused many many people so
what do we do in a very difficult era in
which finally children have some kind of
constitutional rights they actually
became persons in this century we need
to change the statute
of limitations and open up the door so
that instead of worrying about whether
the people who assaulted them are going
to be happy in their lives we'll give
them the opportunity to come forward
when they're ready rather than the
culture we need to improve mandatory
reporting we need to improve background
checks we need to improve the education
of the public we need to improve the
empowerment of survivors in fact
pedophiles don't age out John Gagan the
priest in Boston who was one of the
first to to be named in the Catholic
Church of you scandal was in his 80s
when he was finally found out and he was
still abusing children for each child
sex abuse victim we know from the
studies that it costs about two hundred
and ten thousand dollars extra over the
course of their lives because they were
abused because they were victims of
violent activity so what do we want to
do we've got to prevent sex abuse and
the only way we will do that is by
changing many laws but one of the ones
that we can't change yet if ever is the
fact that if you are convicted of
sexually assaulting a child you need to
be on the registry parents didn't eat
deserve to know who you are and so do
the institutions that will be sued if
they hire the offender without knowing
what's going on thank you
let me Emily take the podium your chance
okay Thank You Marcy so you brought up
Nasir that's a very emotionally charged
in terrible case but he wasn't on the
registry and most of the cases we're
hearing about are not people who are on
the registry I agree with you our
culture has to change we've got to
encourage kids to report we've got to
encourage parents to listen but the
registry is not the answer the registry
is for people who made a mistake the
registry is for people who've already
gone to prison who have already gone to
jail and there is lots and lots of
evidence that after people are arrested
after people are punished they do stop
that's why recidivism rates are very
very low any way you look at it but I
really appreciate that we're having this
conversation because too often these two
sides are isolated and we don't
communicate but let's start where we
agree we all want children to be safe we
all want to reduce sexual assault and
victimization there's no evidence the
registry does any of this there's piles
of evidence that show it doesn't improve
public safety or reduce recidivism it
also gives people who rely in a false
sense of security we've raised the
generation of kids who can't use common
sense to determine real danger versus
fake danger and this is one of the awful
effects of the registry crime has never
been lower but parental anxiety has
never been higher teens have sex it's a
fact in criminalizing teens who have sex
or sex doesn't make a saver safer did we
all in this room wait until we were
legal age to have sex I doubt it Azlan
or scan Daisy here tonight noted in her
recent Cato lecture it's likely many of
us have done things that would have
landed us on the registry lots of bad
things happen to children and adults but
we've elevated sexual wrongdoing and
vengeance for sexual wrongdoing by
saying protect the children we've got to
protect the children to a level that's
out of control out of control we have to
ensure that children and everybody can
ask for help and get it and have their
pleas taken seriously I'm a mother of
four including three girls I want my
girls especially to learn to be
empowered to have the confidence to say
no the recent outpour
of tales about sexual assault often note
how women freeze they can't talk they
can't fight back they say I froze I
don't know why I went up to his hotel
room I don't know why I didn't get out
of the car I went even though I knew I
shouldn't many of the women were hearing
from weren't dragged into the woods by
strangers and raped but for reasons we
need to examine as you said in our
culture about conditioning about gender
roles many of these women are not saying
no let's not banish people who commit
sex offenses and ask them to succeed in
a hostile environment let's fund
programs that teach about the effects of
sex abuse and the importance of
reporting abuse so it can be stopped
common sense and awareness sexual
education and prevention as well as
communication between parents and
children
that's what decreases sexual violence
not naming and shaming those who have
already been named and shamed by all
measures every measure we look at child
sexual abuse is declining we've had a 62
percent decrease since 1990 in 1990
about a quarter of children reported
abuse that's up 50% these laws are an
invitation to discriminate harass and
even physically attack registrants
people on the registry become suspects
for life if your driver's license as sex
offender on it that's an open invitation
to profiling this is just punishment for
the sake of punishment punishment on top
of punishment remember people with a
conviction record already face nearly
50,000 federal state and local legal
restrictions collateral consequences we
don't need more let me underscore that
one of the worst fears that people have
about sex offenses that the people who
commit them will not stop all the
research says that's not true here's my
key point people who are arrested for a
sex offense are less likely to be
re-arrested than any other type of
offender decades of research shows us
this fact recidivism is a non-issue it's
confusing to talk about but it's the
exact opposite of what the Supreme Court
claimed
very rigorous studies have showed us
this in the end we all want the same
thing not punishment for the sake of
punishment in Florida a man works all
day eats dinner with his family at home
then he goes to sleep in a parking lot
why because his home with his family is
too near school we need policies based
on evidence based on facts not fears
need accountability without destruction
and real ways to reduce sexual harm we
need a society where people are allowed
to change and redeem themselves where
victims and offenders get counseling and
support in prison and out we want to
ease the burden on victims reporting
abuse when people aren't figured a
society where people are not fingered or
registered for things they might do
people do terrible things to each other
even to children but the registry is not
the tool to fix it well so then let's go
to the studies that actually are
accurate what the research shows is that
in fact and if you talk to the FBI or
the ones who are experts in this arena
many of these perpetrators have over 150
victims over the course of their lives
that is recidivism that's scary
recidivism what Emily is telling you is
that there is less recidivism about
among sex offenders than there is a
compared to B&E that's ridiculous
recidivism means that the perpetrator
gets more than one child I have to tell
you the thousands of victims that I've
worked with over the course of my career
I don't remember any that just had one
victim and I'm including every family I
don't remember one you know why because
there weren't any so the notion that we
don't have to worry about these people
and we have to worry just make sure that
we protect them is once again what I
said earlier we prefer and we protect
our adults and we don't really care
about kids if we can shove them over to
the side if Nasr had been found out
earlier he would have been on a sex
offender registry and instead of 265
victims who have come forward so far we
might have to so the fact that he's not
on a sex offender registry just shows
the system is broken not that sex
offender registries don't work in fact
we do have a study there's a study out
of Washington State that shows that
with a registration system recidivism
dropped before the registration
recidivism was a certain level after it
dropped there's another group that is
studying the same thing in New York
they're finding the same result in fact
registration has some kind of deterrent
value and if it saves one child from
child sex abuse which can destroy that
child's life and all of their families
then it seems to me that we're talking
about the right thing in terms of having
registration but let me just close by
saying I am I've never heard anything
like the statement that and it kind of
condescending tonig kids can't tell the
difference between real danger and fake
danger hello talking about child sex
abuse kids can't tell that this
perpetrator is grooming them is using
them to get what that perpetrator wants
so it's true they can't tell and that's
why they're at risk and that's why
adults need the registry to know who to
keep their children from thank you thank
you Marcy we the debaters have decided
to waive the right to ask each other
questions so start thinking about
questions that you want to ask and I
tell both debaters please grab the mic
about your that you've got and don't
hold it that close to your mouth but do
hold it close enough to talk before we
turn it over to audience questions I'm
sure you'll have a good many good ones I
want to take moderators prerogative to
ask question of my own while also
finding out what kind of questions are
coming in from the virtual space my
first question just one question to each
of the debaters Emily Marcy has
stipulated I believe that that she would
waive all sex offender registries for
the Romeo and Juliet cases essentially
she would focus
cases miners right - yes right
essentially it would be only for those
over 18 could you could you define what
you mean first could you define what you
mean by recidivism and then second can
you affirm that those over 18 those
category of sex offenders that that
recidivism rate is no higher than the
recidivism rate for other felonies so
first what is recidivism in your view
and is it no higher for that population
that Marcy has stipulated she yourself
would focus on okay
so recidivism rates that I'm talking
about are being rehearsed 'add and
reconvicted for another sex offense and
a meta-analysis in 2014 of 21 of the
most rigorous studies found the
recidivism rates were very low for all
types of sex offense including those
over 18 yes the majority yes including
those over 18 no higher no higher than
for other felonies lower than for any
other category of crime that we track
and it's great that you think minors
shouldn't be on registries however when
the laws were passed in 1996 minors were
not on the registries and then child
advocates fought to get minors on the
registries in 1996 minors were not on
them in 2006 the Adam Walsh act put them
on them which is why we have to start
over when you have a law that people
want to make it tougher and tougher and
tougher so we added minors after ten
years of evidence that the laws weren't
working Thank You Emily my one question
for Marcy Marcy
we have other felonies that have many
hundreds of victims
we have muggers muggers have had
hundreds of victims
we have secondary murderers we have
arsonists who threatened children we
have burglars would you if you say
better to have registries to save the
life of one child would you want to have
registries for all of these felonies
given your concern
that arsonists might kill children
through burning that muckers might kill
children all of them having multiple
offenders would you want to have
registries for all of these felons as
well
the reason that the reason that the
registry is particularly important in
child sex abuse arena is because of the
way the perpetrators operate they
operate in a universe where children
don't see what's coming they can't see
what's coming they're either being
groomed or they're being loved and so
they cannot figure out that they need to
protect themselves every crime you've
just mentioned is a crime of violence
that it is possible that you might be
able to figure out if someone's coming
at you with this problem you think a
child knows a mother is coming with an
arsonist is coming a child definitely
doesn't know that sexual assault is
coming well what about arson a mugging
or burglary they're not on the same
plane they're completely different don't
arsonists kill children to know you tell
me
I believe yeah they're burned houses
down where children look okay anyway
you've answered the question and I
followed up and we want to fill it over
to questions from the audience and do I
see a first question please phrase your
question as a question and take it away
the first questioner so you know the sex
registry I just tells people what your
address and workplace are and so forth
but it doesn't tell you whether the
person next to you in the subway is a
sex offender or the person sitting next
to you here tonight as a sex offender
years ago that Massachusetts Bay Colony
solved this problem by requiring sex
offenders for life to wear a Scarlet
Letter identifying their sex crime and
what is your question do you think that
we should endorse the adopt such a
policy hester prynne because a letter a
for her sex crime of adultery do you
think through the sector registry should
be expanded to have some visible mark on
sex offenders so that you can spot them
in exactly so that you can spot them and
so the question was should sex offenders
have markers so they can be spotted on
some way I would say absolutely not no
surprise surprising
surprising answer for Marcia fun by
Emily absolutely not
Marci your opinion about the subway
question that's probably
unconstitutional actually I think you've
got a problem with that sex offender
registries aren't well it's changing
though I have a question from the from
the virtual space the the Constitution
prohibits cruel and unusual punishment
and also the Fifth Amendment says no
person shall be subjected to the same
offense twice would you say that
question for you Marci would you say
that that sex offender registries are
cruel and unusual punishment or that
they violate the Fifth Amendment along
with the courts that have been
addressing these issues no they're not
but once again child sex abuse is
different it's a different crime it's so
insidious this is just one of the tools
we need it's just one of them we're
doing a terrible job we're not finding
the pedophiles where they are we're not
learning what we need to learn so for
the time being this is one of the tools
is it perfect or any of the tools
perfect no but as between protecting the
child and worrying about the sex
offender who has been convicted of
sexually assaulting a child I'm inclined
to protect the child any comment from
you Emily are doing um I would just say
why not take all the millions and
millions of dollars that we're spending
on registries and find things that work
and fund prevention programs and other
programs to help prevent this instead of
access punishment well one way to
prevent is to know who the pedophiles
are but the data shows it doesn't
prevent the - there's no it's not show
that yes it mentions law was passed in
1996 in New Jersey in New Jersey the
rate of sex offenses was declining ten
years before it continued to decline
there was no difference before and after
the implementation of Megan's Law in New
York there was no difference before and
after the implementation is that total
red herring
but the it's true sex offenses against
children in the quantum have been
declining that is true what hasn't
changed is the mo of the person who is
going after the child and the mo is make
sure that you get everybody around you
to trust you so you can get as many as
possible it is laughable to think that
we now know one how many children any
sex offender on the registry has
actually abused and two that we know
enough that we we don't really need to
worry about this anymore
children are being sexually assaulted
every day by adults in a culture that
doesn't care about children this is just
one tool everybody next question from
the audience um I I think that a lot of
people would agree that somebody who
molest a five-year-old child is just a
terrible person and should be treated
horribly but I get the impression that
one can get on these registries for
crimes like public urination when you
just couldn't find a restroom and really
had to go or you know consensual sex
between two adults who were camping in
the woods out out in the open and some
jerk takes a picture of them and turns
them in and and it's indecent exposure
and now there's sex criminals for life
and they're on this registry and they
can't go nearest within hundreds of
yards of a school and they can't get a
job and their lives are ruined is is
this really appropriate um would you
like s question for you must he would
urination in public places is that a sex
offense if it's on a child on a child
but not not if it's not if you pick dr.
Birol saying okay so a person a question
from from the virtual space a question
from a gentleman who wants to identify
himself as Steven Shiro in the virtual
space
whatever happened to prison as paying
your debt to society what are the crimes
are treated this way murderers don't
have a registry arsonist owned muggers
don't provided offenders released from
prison indications they're no longer
well no longer threat society what
justifies placing them on a list as if
they still are it's either one or the
other no well thank you
Steven could you cope with that question
marcy paying your debt to society
whatever happened to that four month
four markers and murderers and rapists
and an arsonist right they pay their
debt but not such factors I think Oh
back to the foundation what is the
purpose of a sex offender registry about
children who've been sexually assaulted
it's to keep more children from being
assaulted you can make all the arguments
you want about these others saw these
other crimes knock yourselves out we're
talking about whether or not we're going
to try to keep children safe from a
danger that we're having a really hard
time identifying Nasr is not an unusual
case it's just a much more public case
what you know about with Nasr is that
every adult in that universe let those
kids be abused whether they understood
it or not that is true about the sex
assaults I can tell you about families
right that's true about the sex assaults
that go on in the Boy Scouts that's true
about the sex assaults in the
ultra-orthodox community it just is the
reality so while I find it fascinating
as an academic should we think about
maybe having a sej astray that's that's
beside the point the question here is
what are the what are the best ways to
protect children from pedophiles
and can we do it and is this ever useful
and the answer is yes it is well I mean
I just want to say Nasser committed
those crimes in the context of a
registry in the context of the harshest
sex offense policies on earth no other
country has policies like this they're
not effective they're not working I'm
not here arguing a you know in favor of
child sex abuse nobody is everybody
wants to protect the children I disagree
I think everybody wants to protect
children from danger and that's a
primary goal that's driving all of these
laws but I'm here talking about justice
these are people who go to prison prison
in the United States is a really hard
place parole probation there's many many
consequences once you're caught and
convicted and if we don't give these
people a second chance what what does it
mean to even be human it's a terrible
way of looking at society and humanity
well and for the sex assault victim they
kind of see it differently the sex
assault victim they suffer their whole
lives and for the one that gets
assaulted because we didn't bother to
name the person we knew about their
lives are absolutely destroyed so yes
this is about whether or not we care
about children that's really what it's
about another question from from the
virtual space this one for Emily from
Amanda Vaughn Duras out in our virtual
space to what extent questions for Emily
to what extent do you think the low
recidivism is because of the offender
less I think that's not true because the
recidivism rates were declining the
recidivism rates have remained contact
constant so there was low recidivism
rates for sex offenses in studies done
in the 50s 60s and 70s and a study in
New Jersey that looked at the impact of
Megan's Law showed the recidivism rates
were constant before and after and the
sex offense rates were consistent before
and after the implementation of Megan's
Law so these laws didn't create low
recidivism rates the recidivism rates
were low before these laws I
you know what would be really great is
no recidivism it's not persuasive to say
that it's low it's only 5% or whatever
it is what the FBI tells you as I said
before is many of these perpetrators
have over a hundred and hundred and
fifty victims over the course of their
lives NASA again is not unusual you know
what's different about Nasser we had a
judge that permitted kids that were
outside of the statute of limitations to
give victim impact statements we had a
judge's said everybody get in here and
look at him and tell him what he did to
you
yes Nasser was in the context of a sex
offender registry universe and he was
not subjected to it you know why because
nobody came forward and understood what
they were seeing
so do sex offender registries work by
themselves absolutely not are they a
tool that is to be added on to all of
our other tools to try to end this
pandemic it seems to me they have to be
next question from the floor
hi how would either of you address the
idea that the sex offender registry
violates the rights of privacy to you
Marci more as a challenge right sex
offender registry I think it does
violates the right to privacy I think
you gave up your privacy the day you
sexually assaulted a child on that issue
and that's what the courts have said you
know many people on the registry
assaulted adults also but well I'm not
talking about adults am i I'm only
talking about children oh you are no sex
offender ratio rate for people who
assault adults sexually nice is that
clarification no no I'm not saying we
shouldn't have them I'm just saying oh
okay the strongest argument is by far
the children okay but what about the
privacy of those have assaulted adults
they're forfeited that right also there
is no such right that's a made-up right
that the courts have not identified okay
you know it's very easy to talk about
rights that don't exist but they have to
have been court
as part of the Constitution that's not
thank you Oh next question um this
question is for Emily um why is prison a
preferred punishment above a sex
offender registry like why is that
punishment okay and isn't murder or
arson or any other violent felonies
aren't they public can you hide that if
you've you know if you've gone to prison
for murder no I I don't think prison is
above that it's just that people on
registries are people who've already
served their time so they've gone to
prison already that answer your question
next question hi my question is from
Marcy so I know Emily talked about this
a little bit but there's lots of
residency laws around people who are
convicted of sex offenses in New York
State for example we have a
thousand-foot law I was wondering if you
could speak on how that law protects
children in your opinion when I know the
research doesn't quite play this out and
I secondly would ask I know you're not
talking about adults here but do you
think that the resident residency
requirement should be applied to adults
as they are in New York State for people
who are level 3 sex offenders regardless
of whether the underlying crime involved
a child could you summarize that
question why see before you answer it's
a good complex question but summarize it
for the audience makes sure the question
is focused sure so the resident the
question is is separate from
registration it's about residency
requirements that have been piling on
which are basically driven in for
example in Miami all of the sex
offenders are under one bridge it's my
view that the residency restrictions are
ridiculous they make an absolutely no
sense but they're different from a
registration what the residency
requirements say is you can't live here
or you can't live there you know even if
you don't live there you might still
walk by a school so I don't think
they're very effective they're also much
more likely to be unconstitutional so so
you would don't there should be no
residency restrictions and requirements
on sex offenders so long as we have a
decent registration I think that the
residency is is not necessary actually
more effective yes comment from you I'd
agree the register residency
restrictions are bad
laws but they're part of the scheme
there we have a moment of harmony
between the two debaters but they still
do seem to disagree on the resolution
next question from the floor thank you
hi um I think you mentioned 900,000
people we're currently on the registered
sex offender list what percentage of
those people are people like Larry
Nassar versus Romeo and Juliet
situations there's a factual question
perhaps you can't deal with it
Emily would you know well the
distinction I will say 95 percent of the
people who are on the registry are
first-time offenders so they don't have
a history of prior sex offense
convictions okay so they're not but
that's about all you know in terms of
the breakdown offhand at the breakdown
of the robbing the younger people versus
the old right people under 30 are
over-represented african-american men
are over-represented how about people
under 18 how many well there's it's not
clear how many people under 18 are on
the public registry but we do know that
about a quarter to a third of those who
sexually abuse children are children
themselves mmm that's not to say they're
all on the registry some states don't
put children on the registry some states
do in some states there's children as
young as nine on public registries do
you want to come in Marcy oh well I mean
let's just look at the numbers in a
country that has what about 325 million
people and sex offenders run about 2.1
to 2.5 percent of the population nine
hundred thousand is a small number it
sounds big by itself
but for the actual likelihood of
existing sex offenders there are a whole
lot that are not being reported and
aren't out there our next question
um you've mentioned that the the
registry is just a tool and I was
wondering if you could talk a little bit
about how that works in conjunction with
other things like for example statute of
limitation reform or what other tools
work together to make the registry more
effective Kruschev um washing session so
I mean it's my view that the by far the
most important thing that we have to do
to figure out who our pedophiles are is
through statute of limitations reform
the vast majority of United States until
recently has cut the victims out so by
the time they're ready they don't get to
name anybody and if they do name someone
and they're not in statute they get sued
for defamation and that happens again
and again and again so it's my view
that's the baseline once we let the
victims come forward when they're ready
and they can name the perpetrators and
when they name them if the criminal
statute of limitations hasn't expired
they can be sent to jail that's the best
possible universe everything else we're
doing mandated reporting these kinds of
registries background check requirements
all of these are buttresses but so long
as we shut victims out of the court
system we're just not going to know what
we need to know about that about child
sex abusers comment from you Emily oh no
okay next question well I have a couple
of questions in there for Marcy the
first one I have is you had said
something about that children didn't
have a lobby and first I'd like to know
what you base that on what what study
you base that on I personally have met
lobbyists in different states the one
that I'm from they have a strong Lobby
and I know other states do that are
there to testify are there to tell
stories but they do have a lobby
what do you Lobby and the other thing
was that they do have a lobby and some
kids just want because we've had sexual
abuse in our family
and they just want to move on they don't
want to relive it you know forever
and so I'd like to know where you got
the study saying that they didn't have a
lobby because they are and they're very
effective in there and there are new
questions new questions to do statement
that she made about they didn't have a
Lobby their children don't have a lobby
that you want a question you want a
question about that
lobby lobby okay thank you for your
question would you address it more so so
let me rephrase it they have a powerless
lobby I completely disagree and I deal
with these issues in all 50 states the
the ability of children's issues to get
to the forefront for the vast majority
of our state legislatures and for our
federal system it's extraordinarily
difficult it's so difficult it's so much
easier to get state legislators to pay
attention to taxes or to bring business
into the state or anything else that
interests an adult so while we do have
testimony by children frequently maybe
or at least former child victims their
issues are the easiest issues to table
and that's just that's just the reality
and anybody who works in the child
protection universe like I do will tell
you they're about the least powerful in
the Capitol they are nothing compared to
Pharma insurance and the Catholic
Bishops uh Emily no okay a question from
a virtual space for Marcy a question
from Pat gal monde in the virtual space
should there be any way to remove
oneself from the registry should there
be any way for somebody to be able to
remove himself or herself from the
registry once we have the kind of
treatment and proof that someone is not
going to reoffended course we don't have
that yet and so I'm more than willing to
protect the child from the person who is
already sexually assaulted another child
that's how you're talking about comment
Emily well we know low-risk offenders
have very low rates of riah fence right
and even the highest risk offenders
after 15 years there's almost no risk of
reoffending without any treatment we
know that after 15 years people who
commit sex offences desist
that's ridiculous it's not okay wait
wait kick please they don't age Mehta
they do not age out they use a
meta-analysis of 21 studies by Carl
Hanson showed across the board there is
distance even for the highest risk the
lowest risk right away have a 1 to 5
percent chance of repeating I'm not
assuming it's a meta-analysis I didn't
do it it's by Carl Hanson it was
published in 2014 you're assuming I'm
not assuming anything and I'm giving you
data I'm giving you data Carl Francis
Mehta and our family 2014 social
scientists will tell you that pedophiles
do not stop preying on children child
pornographers do not stop just because
they get or I'm talking about not I'm
talking about people convicted of sex
offenses you can call them whatever you
want these are human beings who are
convicted of sex offenses and their rate
of their recidivism rates decline
steadily over time by 15 years even the
highest risks have a very very low risk
of reoffending that you have a risk of
reoffending
between the two debaters which is what
we do in a debate so next question from
the floor yes this question is for both
of you isn't one of the problems with
the registry that as Emily mentioned
earlier
african-americans are over-represented
indigent people are over-represented
really that the powerless in society
they're the ones who can't afford good
lawyers who are often coerced into
pleading guilty when the charges aren't
strong whereas the Larry Nasser's of the
world you know the reason they get away
with it time and time again is because
they're powerful men supported and
shielded by powerful institutions
so that's your question comment on the
statement please bar C or Emily okay do
you want to come in Marcy I would agree
that those without power are over
represented on the registry and in all
areas of the criminal justice system the
the powerful are sexually abusing at the
same rates as the powerless we are in
the me to movement Harvey Weinstein was
taken down
Larry Nasser was taken down priests have
been repeatedly taken down that will
change that percentage will change we
didn't want to think that our most
powerful and important men were actually
doing horrible things to children or
anybody else but it turns out many of
them are so that it that statistic is a
bleep in history it will change Nasser
is now in jail his ilk will be in jail
just as much thank you I'm next question
from the floor hi
so now that child porn is more easily
available through the internet and
authorities are actively seeking to
convict people that are viewing child
porn online and adding them to the
registry what effect has this had on
finding offenders before they can prey
on children and ultimately reducing
child molestation across the country
because child porn is readily available
on the Internet the FBI can get people
who are looking at child porn before
they engage in a contact offense I
haven't seen any data that shows that
but I have seen a lot of evidence that a
lot of people are getting really long
triple digit prison terms for viewing
child pornography what including people
who are intellectually and
developmentally disabled with no history
of a contact defense what what would be
your a prison term for somebody caught
viewing child pornography Emily my
prison term what prison term would you
want to impose on that planet person I
mean they should go to prison I don't
know I'm not a lawyer and I don't
I don't feel comfortable making a
sentencing decision but I think they
should be punished
kamar absolutely I don't think they
should be killed and they comment from
you mushy on the question yeah so the
best recent studies show that child
pornography is a gateway to child sex
assault and so if you can stop someone
at the pornography level you have a shot
at stopping some of the sex assault
that's just that's just the science
that's out there this is Michael Seto
who's the most eminent child pornography
researcher he says that there's a lot of
evidence that there are people who do
view child pornography and it for
whatever reason maybe it's an outlet
maybe they're not comfortable committing
a contact offense but there's a lot of
evidence that it doesn't directly lead
to a contact defense in the same way
smoking pot doesn't lead to heroin you
know it's not there's not it's not
causal there is no evidence that looking
at least according to Michael Seto
something though I'm not an expert in
this area but this is what the studies
show with all due respect well that's
you can't sit over there and say that
you have studies and when I tell you
what the scientists say the child
Michael Seto is the person here there
isn't one person in the trauma ecology
field no in choc will tell you which is
the leading group in the country on this
issue is that it definitely normalizes
it it makes it much more likely that sex
assault will occur number one number two
the harm that is done by child
pornography to children is so severe
because even if they are not
individually sexually assaulted they
live their lives in fear that their
image is being viewed all over the world
it turns out to be even more problematic
than a one-time rape believe it or not
so child pornography is a really really
serious problem and the studies are
showing that it's a gateway that it is
not just someone having fun for the
afternoon next question on the floor
when I first read the question early the
question was not about child pornography
wasn't about children it was about
should people be put in
registry for life so in hearing the
comments about this this has been
focused on a linear way away from the
overall the overall purpose of the
registry so my question is in thinking
about myself as a person of color has
the registry been used as a tool to to
negatively impact people of color and I
have cases where it was individual to
high school Noah college athlete who a
white college athlete who raped a woman
assaulted a woman and the judge wrote a
letter all kind of people wrote a letter
this person got off and it was a similar
case where a person of color was accused
of an act and got fifteen years to life
so is this registry used as a tool to
negli be negatively impact people
without power I think that's question
directed you Marcy I think it's Emily
okay I think okay this question is there
is evidence that racial minorities are
over represented on the registry and in
all areas of the criminal justice system
including sex offense prosecutions there
are sentencing disparities racial
disparities and sentencing across the
board what we are seeing is a reduction
in the willingness of anyone to go to
bat for the sexist alter right that was
just routine that's what we did for our
powerful people
so yes the disparity is absolutely wrong
but we're going in the direction where
it just doesn't matter anymore if you're
the most powerful person in the world
and you've sexually assaulted someone
you are going to be in trouble and so it
seems to me the me2 movement is moved us
into much better territory on that very
issue this will have to be our last
question
last question from the floor before we
get to the summations so give us your
question please yes so since it's been
mentioned that this is about the sex the
registry in general and not just about
children I think the question is Marcy
do you feel that despite everything that
you said with regards to who you don't
want to be on the registry right so
Juliet in Romeo Romeo and Juliet cases
and and the like and the fact that like
you said the fact where they
doesn't matter because they can do it
anywhere and to your point that if
someone's hiring that person as a coach
or so on if they've already been
convicted which would be the only case
that they would be on the registry then
they should do that in the checkup and
see if they have a court case against
them if they've been convicted of a
crime they don't need to be on a
registry for them to know that so do you
still believe that the refugees should
stay intact as it is now even though
it's not protecting all of these cases
including NASA which is the case that
you keep bringing up where really the
problem there is perhaps more an issue
of not punishing the people who saw and
said nothing I think that you and that
statement was you Marcy so could you
come in uh do you want to do you want to
self do you want to briefly summarize
the argument you've been heard as you
understand it before so I'm more than
happy to agree that children should not
be on the registry because they're
treatable we do know that as a matter of
science we know that it's possible to
turn them around and they don't they
will not become recidivists we don't
have the same kind of comfort with older
people so so is the registry something
that we need I do think we continue to
need it is it unfortunate that some
people are on the registry and have
terrible lives yes but for those who
have committed sexual assault it is a
way of preventing it from happening to
other people so yes I will stand by it
for now
if we find it therapy let's go for it uh
why don't you hold if you want to
comment to Emily once you hold that for
your summation which will come up in a
moment those who didn't get a chance to
ask to ask your questions I'm sure that
the beta's will be hanging out at the
bar afterwards and you'll get a chance
to chat with them so we're gonna have a
summations Emily please come to the
podium and give us your summation
all right registrations register 20
years after registries blanketed our
country there's a whole lot more
evidence in I know Marcie disagrees with
this but there is no rigorous credible
evidence that the registry includes
Public Safety and it's not just that we
disagree this is what the data shows
there's no rigorous and credible
evidence that the registry registry
decreases recidivism registries cost us
so much money hundreds of millions of
dollars in state and federal funds these
solid figures are very hard to come by
recently a study in California found
that it's been sixty five million
dollars a year and that state has
one-eighth of the total registrants in
the country there's another really
important cost that's hard to quantify
but we have to consider the damage done
to those on the registry for starters
that's damaged their loved livelihood as
well as their future prospects we're all
concerned with children and their
welfare but all the metrics of crime are
going down the overwhelming number of
sex offenses against children are
committed by first timers and someone
known to the victim not by a registrant
the long and short there's a very strong
case to be made against the registry
what would happen if it disappeared all
the other laws all the other criminal
laws remain in place there are increased
penalties for repeat offenses refitted
recidivism in sex offense cases has been
wildly exaggerated we know this it
should be handled just like other
offenses it's not low because of the
registry a 2008 study in New Jersey
found it had no effect on recidivism or
first-time sex offenses or on reducing
the number of victims the rates were the
same for a decade before and a decade
after Megan's Law the registry re
punishes people who have already paid a
price and been punished and the registry
has such harsh impacts that it's a setup
for failure we all want to protect the
children but we have to do it in a way
that's based on facts not fear and we
can't pander to emotion we have to be
smart and we have to do the right thing
thank you so much
[Applause]
summation from Asti take it away so I
believe in Emily's rush to eliminate the
registries what she's doing is she's
sacrificing the children it's not zero
recidivism it's significant recidivism
and if you have a circumstance
scientifically as we know from the
experts where many perpetrators have
more than one victim the notion that you
must repeatedly convict them in order to
solve the problem means that we're just
going to sacrifice more children and why
is that the vast majority of sex assault
and sex offenses are not prosecuted why
because our prosecutors our elected
officials they want to have winning
records you need evidence beyond a
reasonable doubt to convict someone the
vast majority of sex assault especially
of children is never prosecuted that
means the vast majority never makes it
on to a registration that's why the
number is 900 thousand not the actual
percentage it would be of three hundred
and twenty five million people here I
understand the concern about adults I
hear it all the time I understand that
we have to be deeply concerned about an
adult who's going to lose his livelihood
if in fact someone finds out that he
sexually abused a child but I'm not
willing to sacrifice all of those
children in a rush to make sure that the
adults who sexually assaulted the child
we know about so what what do we need to
do here we need to actually look to
science to develop is it possible to
treat someone who is the person who
abuse five children 10 children 15
children let me just close by set
telling you about a call I got yesterday
I got a call from a family out in
Illinois and they told me that they
wanted to know what to do
because there was someone in their
community who
was sexually offending children I saw
what you have to go to the authorities
and they said well they went to the
authorities but it wasn't enough so how
do you know that he's a sex offender if
the police won't investigate and their
answer was that he was on the sex
offender registry in another state
god bless those people that they know to
protect their children
I fear the world that Emily would like
you to live in where we don't identify
the perpetrators before we're capable of
treating them Thank You Jane you're
opening the app to cast the final vote
on the resolution all those all laws
requiring people to register as sex
offenders should be abolished you'll can
vote for against or still undecided on
the resolution please do so Jane will be
watching the voting people in the
virtual space will be voting people in
our physical space will be voting and
she will shortly be closing the voting
and giving me the results meanwhile let
me again announce that next Monday March
19th we're going to have clearly a
related debate on this topic we
cordially invite our debaters to return
you both get free tickets to the next
month's event Stony Brook University
sociology professor Michael Kalin Kimmel
will defend the resolution there is a
rave culture on college campuses that
creates an unsafe environment for female
students against journalist cafe young
author of the injustice of the rape
culture theory on Monday April 16th
Mises Institute senior fellow Robert
Murphy will defend the resolution
fractional reserve banking poses a
threat to the stability of market
economies against George Celgene
director of the Cato Institute's Center
for monetary and financial alternatives
on Monday May 14th Bryan Caplan
George Mason University economist and
author of the forthcoming book the case
against education no longer forthcoming
in fact the book has been published
the case against education will defend
the resolution all government support of
higher education should be abolished
against Edward Glaeser professor of
economics at Harvard University and then
on Monday July 2nd that's the event that
is quickly selling out so buy your
tickets this evening George count of the
owners I'm sorry July July 2nd is that
at that event on on Bitcoin with Erik
Voorhees and Peter chef but prior to
July 2nd we will have our Monday June
11th debate which will I know will also
be a popular one Georgetown Law
Professor Randy Barnett will defend the
resolution u.s. the US Constitution
should be interpreted and applied
according to the original meaning
communicated to the public by the words
of the text against Cornell Law
Professor Michael dwarf Jane where do we
stand on the voting do you want to ready
to report the results oh my gosh ok
please come to the stage ok
voting YES on the resolution and the
initial phase we got was 39% of the vote
voted yes post it climbed to 72 percent
that's a 33 percent climb so that's the
number to beat
Massey had the nose had 22% and fell a
bit therefore did not match the 33
percent therefore the tootsie roll goes
to Emily congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]